One of the loudest complaints that we've heard
from Donald Trump since the start of the impeachment
[inaudible]
and it's a complaint that his supporters have
started parroting as well, is Trump's not
getting any due process in this impeachment
inquiry.
Donald Trump has now chosen to at least initially
waive the due process that he has been given
because once again, their complaints aren't
based.
In fact, they are merely whatever they can
come up with at the time to try to claim that
they are the victims.
They are the martyrs.
They are the people that are being treated
unfairly.
Now, at the start, before the impeachment
inquiry was even formalized by Democrats,
Donald Trump said, I've got no due process
here.
People around him love the talking point.
They started repeating it ad nauseum and adults
had to explain to Trump and to his followers
will hold.
Hold on a second.
Donald Democrats are just deciding whether
to do an impeachment inquiry.
Due process isn't an issue here.
When Democrats formalize an inquiry, which
they eventually did, they voted on it.
They outlined the limits of the inquiry and
they also outlined the due process that Donald
Trump would get.
Donald Trump now gets to have that due process
if he wants it tomorrow.
We have impeachment inquiry hearings starting
in the house judiciary committee.
We will be streaming the entire hearing live
on our YouTube channel and Donald Trump is
waiving due process by choosing not to participate
in choosing not to have any of his attorneys
participate.
White house lawyer, Pat, chip baloney has
told the house judiciary committee Trump isn't
going to participate.
No lawyers for Trump are going to participate
in the first impeachment hearing of the week
scheduled for tomorrow.
Now I want to be really clear about something
they meaning Trumpists will say, you know,
Trump's still isn't getting due process because
the participation that he's being offered,
even if he did it would be totally skewed
and biased because Democrats control the committee.
Well hold on a second.
Uh, we have two parties in the United States
that flipped back and forth between controlling
the house and the Senate and the idea that
when the other party is in power, you are
denied due process by default because they
don't agree with your politics.
It's number one laughable, but more importantly
that doesn't take into account what due process
is.
Donald Trump got the due process.
He wanted due process.
Is the normal systems notify you and allow
you to have a say and to participate? Trump
was notified and given an opportunity to be
heard.
He is opting not to.
He got due process period.
He received and for now they may choose to
participate later.
For now is waiving due process.
The president is having to be treated like
a little kid and incredibly, there are people
who praise the president simply for not going
out of his way to unfairly attack others.
That's how the discourse has been debased
where when Trump can avoid insulting someone,
he is praised for acting like an adult.
It was never about due process, just like
it's never actually about any of the things
that they say.
It's about, these are simply ways that they
figure out to either try to attack someone
else or to play themselves as the victims
and the reaction is always either outrage,
demanding an uproar, and then when they're
asked to follow through, they decline like
they're doing here now they're again, shifting
to the entire process is unconstitutional
to begin with.
Why?
Well, the, you might say it's a process outlined
in the constitution.
How could it be an unconstitutional process?
Well, the latest complaint is it's supposed
to happen in the house judiciary, not in the
house Intel committee where they held hearings
two weeks ago.
Well tomorrow, the hearing start in the house
judiciary, so what's the problem now?
Oh no, it's still unconstitutional.
Trump is still being denied due process.
They don't want solutions.
They don't care about legality.
They just want to complain.
They just want to be martyrs.
They just want victim hood.
This really is their strength.
Just to complain and talk about how everything
is so unfair to them.
I'm sort of reminded of a guy pretending to
be tough while yelling, hold me back to his
friends, except his friends aren't really
holding him back.
He's holding his friend's arms to make it
look as though he's being held back.
That is a representation visually of what
the entire Trump administration has been around
these hearings.
It's pathetic and we know the real reason
why it wouldn't be good for Donald Trump to
participate.
He would immediately self incriminate as we've
said before, Trump saying, I guess it was
either early last week, maybe the week before
time is really flying where Donald Trump said
he would be interested in testifying in the
impeachment inquiry hearings.
Yeah, right.
His lawyers would never let them do it much
the same way that they kept them away from
Robert Mueller.
We will have the full live impeachment hearings
starting tomorrow morning.
Um, I believe at 9:30 AM Eastern.
We will start the hearing starting a half
hour later at youtube.com/the David Pakman
show.
I hope you will join us.
I think that these will be very interesting
hearings and also important when it comes
to, uh, starting to hear from folks in the
Trump administration, at least to some degree.
And I look forward to it.
I hope you'll join me.
Of course.
I'm sure Donald Trump will be, uh, actively
tweeting about how everything is just so unfair
now.
He's the victim throughout
the entire process.
We'll pick that
up tomorrow.